explosions light up the night sky in
keev as Russia launches its most intense
drone attack on Ukraine since the
invasion began shattering homes
cars leaving many picking up the pieces
and fearful of what's
next they totally destroyed my balcony
and my kitchen this woman cries I don't
know what I'll do
this woman says they heard the sound of
an engine overhead a second later a
blast came the door was smashed and hit
the opposite wall it literally flew
above our
heads ke's mayor says at least five
people were wounded including an
11-year-old child in the assault that
came in waves for over 6
hours Ukrainian President Vladimir
zalinski condemning the attacks during a
ceremony marking the 19 th anniversary
of hore a famine that killed millions of
[Music]
ukrainians evil was not stopped not
atoned for he says and now we are
stopping it as another winter of War
closes in on Ukraine neither side is
backing down and that's being felt here
in Canada with the recent death of
Joshua Mayers a 34-year-old Edmonton
paramedic who went to help Ukrainian
troops in September his family saying
he's believed to have died in a drone
strike and they were notified of his
death on November 12th that tragic loss
just days after the death of Austin llin
berer a 25-year-old man from op Pasqua
crenation in Northern
Manitoba his community lowering their
Flags to half Mass to honor his heroic
efforts he died his life for what he
believed in and help which is help the
others it's coming up on two years since
Russia launched its full-scale invasion
of Ukraine in that time Global Affairs
Canada says nine Canadians have died out
of the thousands who have lost their
lives as this war drags on Marty blun
Global News Winnipeg